>> Last time, we talked about some cases where you'd want to use branches for
your solo projects.
You might also want to use branches to keep things organized when
working with others.
If you and your collaborators all make changes on the same branch,
you can't easily work on separate features simultaneously.
A common workflow for people working on projects together,
includes making a new branch for every feature or bug-fix.
This way, if multiple people are working on changes at the same time.
They can each check out their branch to continue work after taking a break.
Without worrying about things changing up from under them.
Then once a feature or bug-fix is complete,
the author can either update master to also point to the tip of the new branch.
Or if there have been changes to master in the mean time.
Combine it with the current master, using git's merge feature.
We'll talk about merging in detail later.
I've actually been working on a new feature for
the asteroids game, that adds a new game mechanic.
In addition to getting points for destroying asteroids and
spaceships, you can also collect coins by touching them with your ship.
This adds a new challenge, since there are now somethings that you want to hit
and others that you want to avoid.
I'm finally ready to share this branch with Caroline.
So I tell her that she can check out the branch and play test it,
so that I can get some feedback before adding it into the main branch.
>> Thanks.
Now Sarah told me that her branch is named coins.
So I'll check it out using git checkout coins.
Now, I get this message saying that branch coins is set up to
track remote branch coins from origin.
Whoa.
That's a few words that you haven't heard before.
The fact that it's a remote branch means that I didn't create it myself.
Instead, Sarah created it and so I'm looking at her branch.
You'll learn more about remotes in lesson three.
But for now, once I've checked out the branch,
it behaves just like the branches that I created myself.
Now I'll open the index.html file and try the game out.
Now this is a coin right here that Sarah added.
And when I run into it, then my score goes up.
Cool.
Now you might be wondering why Sarah's version of the game doesn't have color.
That's because Sarah started working on this branch before color was
added to master.
To see this, I'll do a git log.
So I can see that these recent commits are all by Sarah.
If I scroll down to get to the most recent commit that wasn't from Sarah,
I see that it's this one where I reverted the controls back from my
experiment in lesson one.
That's because this was the latest commit on master at
the time when Sarah checked out her branch.
By contrast, if I check out master and run git log there.
I can see many newer commits that are more recent than the commit that
Sarah started working on.
The color commit is right here.
Git can also help you visualize the branch structure via the command git
log dash dash graph.
I'll also add the flag dash dash oneline to make the output shorter and
easier to see.
And I'll need to tell git which branches I want to visualize.
So, I'd like to see master and coins at this point.
These commits existed before the coins branch was created.
These are commits that Sarah added to the coins branch.
And these are commits that were added to master after
the coins branch was created.
Now that you've seen what commits are in each branch, grab a pencil and
paper and draw a diagram of the commit history in the asteroids repository.
Including the easy-mode, master and coins branches.
You don't have to include all the old commits just,
however many of the recent commits you think will be informative.
When you're finished, check this box.
If you're having trouble,
try using git log to see what commits are on each branch.
And make sure you watch the solution video to compare your diagram to Sarah's.